the the whole way the gaming industry is
gone it's like
it's like decades ahead of where the
anime is at i wonder if that's because
they kind of grew at the same time like
the culture of gaming
in america was its own thing and the
culture of and gaming in japan was its
own thing
and they kind of grew together
benefiting each other like they
send games to each other and i wonder if
that's if that's the reason why that
industry
went so fast and why sometimes people
can't even tell if a game is
from japan oh yeah i think it's also
because like yeah like american
games now like now they're making games
in america and in europe whereas like
i feel the anime industry won't do that
until we get
dedicated people who are making it in
america and making it in europe
because i i guess when maybe when the
japanese businessman in like the 80s or
90s are making video games they were
like oh yeah there's chunks of gaming in
the u.s let's go send our products over
there yeah
there's like oh there's no anime there
that's not that's not bothered doing it
i mean i would also say that from my
like perspective i feel like the anime
industry
has always been like in my opinion like
kind of like 10 years
or so behind the gaming industry i
thought 20 something yeah
like 10 10 to 20 years in terms of the
popularity and how
you know how how big the industry is
like gaming
right now is probably the most
mainstream medium
entertainment medium there is now right
gamers sorry
yeah i mean i mean i mean i mean like i
mean gaming makes more than movies now
right yeah
yeah so game gaming right now you can
put micro transactions in a [ __ ]
movie
that's true that's true can't roll for
your gotcha in the middle of parasite
would you like to watch the rest of this
movie five dollars please yeah but like
i would say like within our lifetime
we've seen gaming
we've seen gamers rise up to become
the most biggest entertainment medium in
the world now right what does that mean
it's going to rise
it used to be used to be movies now do i
think anime is going to become as big as
gaming
no but i would say that anime right now
is also rising it's on its way it's on
its way
it's on its way it's getting more
popular but that isn't it weird though
that i feel like all the money
that the weebs have is being siphoned
off in anime games
yeah yeah that is true i bet more anime
games and v
i bet i i bet we spend way more on
anime games than they do on anime merch
100 100 all the weeb stuff all the weed
money they're just going in the [ __ ]
games
it all comes back to the games oh yeah i
mean i i feel like
probably if if you uh if you interviewed
like the average anime fan
like not the average anime fan the
average weeb i would say the average
person in the weeb culture
they probably spend more money on like
games
or like v tubers than they do on an
actual like anime
like a figurine or a manga or something
like that yeah yeah yeah
yeah no absolutely 100 it's it's it's
weird how that
that's just the way weebs work but
that's that's what i that's what i feel
weebs put most of their money into
maybe like maybe it's maybe in 2020
maybe it's because there haven't been
like anime conventions or things other
things they can buy
um but i would say that the more i watch
anime
the less i buy like figurines and stuff
like that you know
do you feel like i mean you're a
hardcore jojo fan right so you
you you put a lot of your money into
jojo merch but
nice to jojo stock yeah yeah but now but
now but now i'm like you look for like
the most exclusive stuff right you don't
just buy like the
the cheap no i don't like if the figures
under like 50 bucks i'm like
yeah yeah exactly i'm like that's
peasant stuff get that out of here
because because
those figures are so cheap and also when
you realize that you start collecting a
lot of figures the one thing that
becomes more valuable than the figures
is the room they take up yeah yeah so
then you're like right now i have to
decide which figures are worthy of the
display
yeah so i'm like slightly starting to do
that too with like
exclusive like paintings or like like
limited
and stuff like that i'm sure that sounds
so [ __ ] uh
sounds so [ __ ] so wealthy i'm an art
collector
but it's like you know when you when you
do start collecting figures and you
start getting a lot you're like
you know this five dollar goku figure
you know i kind of can't argue it
deserve the same spot as this 200
hand sculpted rem [ __ ] like dna
engraved
you know thing like not not even
figurines though but like any time i go
to an anime convention or stuff like
that
i much rather buy [ __ ] from the artist
alley and things that independent
artists are doing because
most of the time they make cooler stuff
than the official figures most of the
time or the official merchandise it's
just like
i i i don't understand people who go to
anime conventions and they buy
buttons to me buttons buttons are the
stickers for me right like the metallics
japan is [ __ ] obsessed with the
ninjas yeah yeah yeah why
whenever i go to like a pop-up shop for
like you you hear you hear
an announcement where oh there's a
pop-up shop for like x anime series or
why anime series and i remember the
first few times i thought
wow cool they got exclusive merch there
and it's like 90
of them are just buttons and to me like
buttons
are the merch you buy when you don't
when you can't commit to buying an
actual merchandise
that's that's that's what that's like
that chump change yeah yeah yeah right i
would pay for this yeah it's it's like
the equivalent
of you know when you go abroad and
you're like oh i guess i gotta buy a
souvenir right yeah you go to paris and
you go
you go like i guess i gotta buy like a
[ __ ] eiffel tower key ring
yeah it's literally the equivalent of
like i was here
yeah like i was at that pop-up store
here is physical proof
i was at that pop-up store a 500 yen
shitty like cam
like tin can thing yeah but then they
got your fight so you can't even buy the
one you want you think
yeah you have to buy like 500 [ __ ]
buttons until you get the one you want
there are people though that i see that
have you know like all the whole bags
their entire bag or their entire like uh
denim jacket or whatever it's just like
covered in them and they just they sound
like a [ __ ] festival
why would you put a bunch of barnacles
on your clothes as far as i'm concerned
right
that's what it looks like it looks like
it looks
it's ugly and i won't stand for people
like it man yeah